hey guys welcome to the reuben report i
am dave rubin i've got two tyt all-stars
with me john idarola kim horcher and
we've got a lot to talk about so all
right it was a pretty good week so far
for the gays that's right the supreme
court let stand five federal appellate
court rulings so a bunch more states are
getting gay marriage uh utah oklahoma
virginia wisconsin and indiana so we've
got an updated gay marriage map
all right there you go
dark blue fully legal uh and the light
blue are the new states and uh
the gray
they like that traditional old-fashioned
marriage do you guys want to comment on
that
yeah yeah exactly anything else
interesting do you find anything
interesting gays like water apparently
everything close to water except down
if you're gonna you can have like super
conservatives like to one side of you
you don't want to be surrounded by them
ideally yeah not much surprising about
that map i mean new mexico possibly
that's pretty much it in terms of the
long-established ones okay so the
interesting thing i think about this is
cnn's jeffrey toobin who's their chief
legal analyst he basically said that the
supreme court did not do their duty by
not hearing this case because that's
what would have led to all the states in
the union getting gay marriage but don't
let me speak for him let's listen in
well you know this is why we have a
supreme court right to settle
complicated controversial legal issues
frankly i think it's outrageous that the
court didn't take this case i mean you
know the way the court works is it takes
four votes to to agree to hear a case
it's five votes to
reach a judgment but four votes to to
hear a case and apparently there were
not four votes to take these cases now
the justices may say though they don't
explain these rulings look there is no
controversy in the in the courts of
appeals now they have all ruled that
same-sex marriage is the law we don't
need to settle a disagreement
there could be some strategic voting
going on on the part of some of the
justices saying we don't want to take
this case because our side may lose
that's something that goes on but
frankly i think um this was a real
abdication of duty on the part of the
supreme court really the discussion
about same-sex marriage has been going
on in this country for quite some time
and the excuse me and the country has
changed so much
and there are so many states that have
it now that you know yes
the court shouldn't get ahead of the
public but you know the public is you
know now
all the polls show a majority favor
same-sex marriage
it's a place where uh it seems to me
it's past time for the supreme court to
step in but you know what i don't get a
vote
okay so so i think that's really
interesting what he's saying there so
yes we got some more gay marriage that's
pretty good most people are down with
that but that the court itself didn't
really do what its duty is um
this seems this seems kind of shitty
like when i saw originally on twitter
when i saw it rolling in i was like oh
this is all good all good we're getting
more states are coming around but
ultimately isn't this exactly what the
supreme court is supposed to do aren't
they supposed to take the challenging
cases they literally legally abided by
what they were supposed to do and he's
like well i don't think this is right
i'm with the anchor michaela pereira
like really you think this is outrageous
in a legal abdication but shouldn't they
aren't they supposed to take the tough
cases and when something is being talked
about nationally as this has been going
on long enough aren't they supposed to
jump in and say this is what the law of
the land is i think two tuban's mostly
historically accurate there in that when
you have two different sets of laws like
you're treating one group of people two
different ways in different states
they're supposed to step in but not it's
not especially the way it is right now
it's not so much that the laws are
different in different states generally
historically
when it's a seriously contentious social
issue the supreme court will step in not
when the laws are different but when
different like um different district
judges and things like that are ruling
differently like if you had a supreme
court a same-sex marriage ban knocked
down in one state and then upheld by a
district court and then in a different
state it's struck down by a district
court usually when there's judicial
disagreement that's when the supreme
court will step in so it's almost close
enough to that though that's good
it seems like in in all of these cases
that we were talking about that they
might have picked up it was basically
that the the law was saying you can't
have same-sex marriage and then the the
judiciary was saying you can there seem
to be pretty widespread agreement by the
judges in terms of what the law should
be and so that might not have been
contentious enough judicially for the
supreme court to feel they had to step
in right so as i assume both of you are
for same-sex marriage wouldn't you want
the court to do this we're forgetting
the legal whether they technically
legally had to do it or whether it was
okay wouldn't you want them to step up
and do something that would just get
this issue off the table isn't it are
you sick of talking about it it has been
a long time but you know i do agree that
we need to do what's legally proper
because i stand by
um keeping our legal system legal and
and by the book rather than just you
know well my religion says this and my
feelings say that yeah
i mean look i i think whatever allows it
to be the law of the land would be good
but i would say that if you think that
in five or ten years it's going to be
effectively wide across the entire
country
which is probably going to be the case i
think the best possible way would be for
people's opinions to change and then the
laws to be changed as opposed to it
being mandated by the supreme court
which could in the case of like roe v
wade it could lead to long-standing
resentment by the people who feel like
they ruled the wrong way i would rather
that it was a popular decision right and
it's moving so fast i saw a chart today
i think on vox that compared uh approval
rates for same-sex marriage historically
versus uh inter-interracial marriage
about three decades after it was legally
legally allowed you're able to have
interracial marriage for it to reach
majority approval in the case of
same-sex marriage it's reached majority
approval even before it's legal yeah so
it is happening quickly to me what this
more is about is of course i'm i'm happy
with what happened here uh and i guess
maybe i'm not as patient as what you're
saying which i think is a legitimate
point but it seems to me it just shows
how broken our system is like right now
we're at war in syria congress didn't
vote for it we have branches of
government that are supposed to do
different things so congress didn't vote
on us going to a new country to attack
them forget attacking iraq again that's
fine uh and here the supreme court is
not i just don't see them doing what
they're supposed to do despite pretty i
mean that's a pretty sound argument that
i think you're making yeah well look if
if your argument is that the system is
broken you're going to have widespread
agreement throughout this building with
tyt yeah um
do you think the gay marriage thing is
over i really believe i've been saying
it for a while on the show that the
republicans are actually going to be for
it in 2016 whoever runs we've been
watching uh you know conservative uh
candidates and people in office you know
slowly migrate their views this way as
the popular opinion moves this way which
makes me think maybe you don't care and
you just want the votes and you're just
doing what's popular and if if that's
what it takes
fine
let it be good officials only doing
something because it's popular isn't
that bizarre uh well actually speaking
of that i mean ted cruz really is the
only person
in the republican party who really came
out against this so does that shows that
the republicans are really coming around
right yeah i think i think that even he
will back off i mean traditionally when
you have an issue like this being pushed
by one party it's either because they
think they can make a lot of money off
of it or they can move a lot of votes by
it historically same-sex marriage has
never been an absolutely massive
fundraising tool for the republicans in
the way that like abortion rights are or
something like that and there's so much
overlap in terms of the people who
oppose same-sex marriage with other
traditionally more lucrative issues like
abortion why not just move them on that
issue and and not risk turning off some
moderate republicans who might be in
favor of same-sex marriage all right
there you go call me crazy i'm for gay
marriage and also for a functional
system i know that's nuts but you know
what can i say i'm a dreamer so this
ebola craziness continues i think we did
a pretty good job of breaking down the
science with carol santa maria last week
so if you want to just find out about
the science and the facts of what's
going on uh we we will link to it right
here right where my hand is right now
and you can find out about the facts but
now i want to talk about what's going
forward so the world health organization
is now saying that it is quote quite
unavoidable that ebola will spread
throughout europe and we've got a quote
such imported cases as have happened in
spain will happen also in the future
most likely it is quite unavoidable
because of the extensive travel both
from europe to the affected countries
and the other way around the most
important thing in our view is that
europe is still at low risk and that the
western part of the european region
particularly is best prepared in the
world to respond to viral
hemorrhagic fevers including ebola
now we've got some video of president
obama because he's getting a lot of [ __ ]
basically for people saying he's not
being strong enough we're not doing more
at our borders and at airports etcetera
etcetera so let's listen to the
president i know that
people are concerned about
the possibility of an ebola outbreak and
ebola is a very serious disease
and
the ability of people who are infected
carry back across borders is something
that we have to take extremely seriously
at the same time it is important for
americans to know the facts
that is that because of the measures
that we've put in place
as well as our world-class health system
and the nature of the ebola virus itself
which is difficult to transmit
uh the chances of an ebola outbreak in
the united states
is extremely important
you know our world-class health system
like the hospital in texas that turned
away the ebola patient who actually died
this morning we've got a quote from
obama that i think kind of wraps this
thing up we don't have a lot of margin
for error we're also going to be working
on protocols to do additional passenger
screening both at the source and here in
the united states the good news is that
it's not an airborne disease we know
what has to be done and we have the
medical infrastructure to do it but this
is an extraordinarily virulent disease
when you don't follow the best protocols
okay so right now we don't have a ban on
travel
from or to west africa people are saying
our airport security is two lakhs
etcetera etcetera so again not getting
into the science end of it do you guys
have faith in our system just the basic
system that we have when they say we
have the best healthcare in the world
and we you know the border like none of
that really seems true to me yeah well
it seems like it seems inconceivable in
a country as large as ours with as many
international flights as ours going into
so many different cities which have
different levels of safety regulations
at the airports coming from
international airports that have
differing levels of security it seems
hard to believe that there won't be any
more cases i do think that that we've
been
pretty good as a country in terms of of
of walling it off once it starts like i
don't expect it to spread outside of
dallas and things like that but i don't
think that we've seen the last of it
here in america europe i think is it's
even more likely to come i mean you're
talking about so many different
countries a lot of travel between those
countries i think it's more likely to
spread at least a little bit there yeah
do you have faith in our system well
you know as care explained before with
our um
from a medical and uh hygienic
standpoint it's unlikely to break out
it's very hard it's hard for me to get
away from that point to say like oh we
need to lock everything down but
i do think we need to be paying more
attention to this seriously and and have
a little uh
what is that word empathy for people who
are
in at risk for this yeah what do you
think about i don't want to be alarmist
because i think especially if you watch
cable news everyone immediately watch
fox and the scary graphics and scary
music and all that um but why not for
two weeks let's say just temporarily for
two weeks we're just gonna stop flights
in and out of west africa with that just
while we sort of get our head on are
wrapped around this thing would that be
uh too bridge too far for you it
certainly seems reasonable to me and i
think that if you pulled the american
people there would be widespread
agreement on it but that said i'm not an
expert on what exactly that would entail
what negative uh consequences it would
have and i've heard from people who are
supposedly experts on that issue that
it's not feasible um and i don't think
that those people have some sort of
covert agenda to get ebola into the
country um but but i totally agree with
you as uh rush limbaugh thinks that he
thinks that obama is trying to bring it
here to because yeah
he does feel guilty yeah um but i
totally agree with you about the media
we're we are we as the media are put in
a pretty shitty situation right now
because they have been fear-mongering so
much in the initial weeks of the ebola
outbreak that we feel like we have to be
the counter punch to that and yet we're
also legitimately scared of what we
think is a reasonable worry about ebola
yeah um and and the thing is that the
right wing both is scared about ebola
because one of the main characteristics
of the conservative brain is a
heightened uh fear center but they're
also using it to advance their agenda in
terms of anti-immigration they want to
shut down the borders but they also
wanted to shut down the borders a month
ago they want to use it to attack obama
and to attack any sort of international
peacekeeping or humanitarian efforts i
mean they're trying to like kill 10
birds with one stone with ebola and then
and so on the other side what are we
supposed to do to have people be
rationally scared of it but not insanely
scared yeah so they have a heightened
fear center i thought they have a
heightened money sensor probably i think
they bought up against each other
everything is an attack obama on obama
and it's obama's fault if you haven't
noticed that yet but this isn't
fear-mongering we have this report of
this nurse in spain who's been infected
because she was around people who had
actually died missionaries and you know
these are things that are actually
happening so it is important that we do
discuss this as it is a real topic but
yeah there that it is kind of a
difficult position to say okay that
we're not fear-mongering but this is
what's actually happening right i heard
this morning actually now they're going
to put her dog down too because they
think that that could possibly the dog
could possibly spread ebola so it's just
like the stories just keep getting
weirder and weirder i think which is uh
which is part of it do you think also
part of the the discussion is that we
can't do two things at once i say this
on the show every week we can't debate
two things at once in america so we got
so much going to isis right now which
we're gonna get to in a second that you
if now ebola maybe we can kind of
balance two things but if ferguson
flares up again or something i was like
there's just not enough brain power in
this country to deal with a couple
things at once does anyone remember
ukraine yeah what have they had nobody's
talking about that they took that uh
russia
crimea right yeah put ebola into west
africa actually
and yeah and look look
i guess i i have to say this as a
devil's advocate like when it's
something like ebola which we don't have
a lot of experience with i'm talking
about the average person they don't know
how scared they should be
like we're getting so scared about
something that has killed so far one
person in america legitimately it's
killed over 3000 africa that is scary
and yet look at all the things that we
could stop in america that are killing
tens of thousands every year and we
don't care about try to get somebody
worked up about the long-term effects of
climate change and ah we'll deal with
that in a hundred years or something but
ebola serious issue gotta fix it today
even if it means cutting off all
international travel yeah okay final
thought on this do you think there is
some racial element to this because this
is the new thing that i keep seeing
popping up on twitter that people keep
saying well it's been in africa and it's
killing thousands of people i think
around 3000 people and no one really
cared and now it's creeping here
and it could creep to europe and once it
starts killing white people then people
are going to get upset do you think
that's a legitimate uh i think it's a
complete lack of empathy for people who
aren't directly related to you or your
interests or your status quo
i think
i think i don't know if it's
i don't want to say oh it's racist but
it's definitely like ignorance i would
say yeah well i mean we had the andre
tantaros talking about how people in
america are going to go from west africa
to try to see which doctors instead of
regular doctors so i think that there's
some element of like casual racism there
i think it's gonna be interesting to see
though how conservatives will react if
it gets into europe but it only kills
french people
they'll be very tournament then they'd
be okay with that there you go all right
let's talk about isis uh this thing just
does not end
apparently there's going to be another
beheading of an american this time it
was a british person last week but a
reporter
on friday we're taping this on wednesday
right now uh and an interesting poll
came out that said nearly two out of
three americans back airstrikes in iraq
and syria now 65 of americans back u.s
airstrikes that seems like an incredibly
high number to me a little more than a
third say they're opposed to sending
ground troops uh 53 say they think
there's a higher risk of a terrorist
attack on u.s soil despite the concern
only a third are closely following news
of u.s airstrikes this is perfect storm
for a disaster now since as i've said
since we started this thing congress has
not voted to authorize this war john
boehner mr bravery keeps saying well
obama should call us back in so we can
vote on it i'm pretty sure he doesn't
have to get authorization from the
president to do his job so it's
congress's fault it's also obama's fault
because he's just going ahead and doing
strikes without getting authorization
and yes everyone can argue about the
legal loopholes that they all jump
through to make this happen uh but i
wanted to make this about the american
people because two out of three people
are happy uh bombing these guys um that
seems incredibly high to me considering
we didn't really have a debate about it
when when last year
when assad used uh chemical weapons
there was a debate for a couple weeks
about what we should do should obama get
authorization etc etc now we're bombing
the guys that are fighting assad and
we're not even having a debate about it
so
what's going on i think it's
somewhat understandable to
if maybe you're not completely um fluent
on the subject to want to fight fire or
fire with fire or crazy with crazy uh
but there are going if we well you know
it's not under debate right now but if
we were to do this without that um i
think there's a lot of long-term
ramifications that we're not considering
and you know
a further escalation of violence more
years um
with a military occupation and
i i don't think we're ready to do that
yet yeah all right so i know you're uh
you're a constitutionalist john so
something like that you know about the
government how about that that sounded
good right yeah you know a little so
what do you think about just the
congressional part of it because i keep
talking about it literally nobody's
talking about it it is not discussed in
the news we went to war with a new
country where yes we're not fighting the
regime in syria the guy that we were
gonna fight a year ago who uh john kerry
compared to hitler now we're literally
bombing the people he's fighting but
what about that just the congressional
party i mean if you look back
historically the the way that we go to
war has never really followed with what
i assume the founders thought we would i
mean we tried to get the war powers act
in place to try to reign in the power of
the president to unilaterally send us
into some military conflict that was
weak on day one and it's only weaker on
in year 40 after it was passed so i'm
not super surprised by that especially
when if they were to have the debate in
the house and the senate i think that
they would support it i think that i
knew too which is even more odd that's
surprising that he didn't yeah that is
that is correct um
but i i think one of the reasons that he
feels he can get away with not even
having that debate a debate that he
would almost certainly win but maybe
he's worried that if they had it some
strings would be attached that he
doesn't want it's a lot safer to go it
alone is there's two principle reasons i
think it's been so easy um to get the
american people to back this one that
it's air strikes and it's not a full-on
war with boots on the ground i think
that coming out of the conflicts in iraq
and afghanistan airstrikes seem like oh
that's nothing we can do that we do that
all the time right aren't we airstriking
so many places right and then even more
importantly the war in iraq and
afghanistan was pitched to the american
people as this is not a war against
islam there's a war against these
regimes
now it seems pretty clear that we're
fighting at least some form of islam
yeah there's a lot of anti-muslim
sentiment among them american people
they're not islamic and they're not
yes that's true but you go you go on fox
news and you look at the the you look at
what isis is pointing out and it seems
like that's what we're fighting against
and so i think for the american people
who don't understand and probably at the
very least distrust uh muslims and islam
i think it's easy to get them to want to
constrain that power in some way right
how much do you think has to do with
just the general state of our minds when
it comes to war we're still in
afghanistan um can do you know why we
went there in the first place fight them
over there to fight us here
yeah nobody knows why we're there it's
the longest war in american history we
just signed some pack that means we're
going to be there until at least 2024
and mark my words we will be there long
after that so it's part of this just
that we don't war means nothing to us
anymore sorta john's point of the
airstrikes it's like ah well airstrikes
isn't war even though i'm pretty sure if
someone was air striking us we'd call
that war or wouldn't we well we say
airstrike and we say drone attack but we
don't really think about what that means
a lot of the time yeah yeah and i mean
we talked about the beheading and
there's there's something about the amer
the human brain that they look at a
beheading and it seems so very different
than a bomb that kills 10 people whether
it's a bomb that we drop from a drone or
if it's isis blowing up a village like
we care more about the single hostage
who's beheaded than you know the
thousands of people that have already
been killed by isis and more traditional
violence yeah so where do you guys stand
with the beheading things because we've
talked about it here we've shown some of
the videos um twitter's now not letting
you post the beheading videos themselves
but there's plenty of beheading stuff
out there on youtube um do you think
it's just feeding the propaganda because
i'm sort of of two minds in this partly
i think you have to show it and talk
about it because it's it's happening so
not talking about it doesn't help and
then on the other hand there is the
propaganda version where if we keep
talking about it you just gin up
especially the uneducated people who
just see it and then immediately want to
attack where do you fall on how much we
should talk about and show the visuals
of actually what they're doing well it
is a disgusting and horrible act
to to watch someone lose literally lose
their head but we have to consider how
many other people are
being killed horribly and unjustifiably
as well
it's not to excuse that it's not to let
that go we should mention it at least
yeah but we have a weird thing about you
have to think about it in context right
so it's it's it's it's a it's horrible
this huge picture it's horrible i think
we all agree on that for sure but we
have this weird thing on how people die
that sometimes it's not okay so assad
killed around 100 000 syrians with
conventional weapons everyone seemed
okay with it then the gas thing i think
it was about 200 people everyone went
crazy we ended up not doing anything or
i guess maybe we took the chemical
episode
kinda now we're upset about beheading
again so it's weird to me that we pick
and choose well i guess it does have to
do with the visuals right yeah i mean
they're delivering basically a media
package for people to put on i think
early on it was important for us to show
them both because it was new at that
point and also we wanted people to
understand the severity of the of the
threat that we were facing but now i
feel like one usually on the young turks
if the family says that they want or
don't want it to be shown that's usually
what we go by we don't want to offend
the families who've already been through
so much but perhaps more importantly now
i feel like
isis wants us to show them and so i'm
inclined not to and i feel like if we if
they were to put one out and no one was
to spread it on twitter on on you know
cable news would they be less likely to
make another one i think they'd be
somewhat less likely and so inclined to
not show them right now but they still
might be doing the beheadings not
showing them uh final thought on this
why don't other countries do more uh
which i think i've said in every isis
video that we've done like everyone
hates america for jumping in and trying
to fix things and we always make it
worse and all that uh but it seems to me
like right now uh isis is on the syrian
border they're about to take this town
uh i'm sorry ice is on the turkish
border and they're about to say yeah
they're out there they're in syria yeah
yeah um why don't other turkeys got a
pretty big army i mean all these
countries there they have armies why
why is it that we have to lead everybody
all the time when it's in their
backyards not in our backyards say that
it's a burden that we willingly took on
ourselves after world war ii and have
continued to take on ourselves in every
possible
opportunity i think that first of all
turkey is going to get involved if they
take this town on the turkish side of
the border with syria they're going to
have to respond isis is in an
interesting position right now both that
they can strike inside of turkey
potentially very soon and also that
they're right on the borders of baghdad
we've sort of come to grips with the
current territory that they hold in iraq
and in syria if they take either of
those two particular towns or city in
the case of baghdad i think that then
you might see an international ramping
up and also by the way it is the united
states that's leading the charge but we
do have france and australia which are
contributing to the airstrikes we have
some arab allies including the uae that
have flying missions against isis so it
is almost all us but it's not just us
yeah but we know that it's like 90 of us
something that just seems odd yeah
france and australia we're like we're
all kind of doing it but all the guys in
their own backyards who have weapons who
we give weapons to much like the uae
like we give these guys weapons and then
they still ask us to help i don't know
it is extremely complex so let's talk
about twitter my favorite habit and my
my 140 character addiction uh twitter
right now is suing the us government
they have filed a lawsuit in federal
court uh claiming that the u.s
government uh well they're fighting them
on the right to publish their full
transparency of reports and i think this
is kind of interesting because with all
this nsa stuff that we're hearing about
we know that the nsa can go into your
skype account and see your chats or
whatever it is or the video calls or all
the facebook stuff and gmail et cetera
et cetera twitter is the most
transparent because you're tweeting
publicly so the only really hidden thing
in twitter i guess is the dm so i do
think that's kind of interesting but
we've got a quote from the twitter
representative
we filed a lawsuit in federal court
seeking to publish our full transparency
report and asking the court to declare
these restrictions on our ability to
speak about government surveillance as
unconstitutional under the first
amendment the ninth circuit court of
appeals is already considering the
constitutionality
of the non-disclosure provisions of the
nsl law later this week
so this is interesting as i said twitter
does seem to be more transparent why is
the most transparent social media
company the one that's fighting the us
government kim
i think it's great that they're fighting
for transparency because you know we've
seen this blow back on a a lot of
different social media and also email
and different web platforms of you know
hey we have to tell you this is
happening that's all we can say
and i think you know it's
it's only fair that they should be able
to have some control over what happens
in their own business yeah is there any
chance that they win this lawsuit i mean
the nsa is just going to do what it wait
the fed if they win like they're going
to do it anyway right or that that they
okay congratulations you won and now
we're going to figure out some backdoor
channels to take the information yeah
well i i think it's unlikely at this
point that they're going to win which is
why it's so unsurprising that they're
publicizing the fact that they're
fighting them if you know that you're
not going to be able to beat the u.s
government why not at least get the sort
of authenticity and credibility that
comes from being seen to be trying to
fight them i mean it's it's like sort of
a i don't know a silver lining i suppose
the issue have you guys kind of given up
on the online privacy thing you know
there was a point maybe six months ago
where especially around here and and in
most circles on the left at least where
we were talking about this constantly
right just constantly talking about and
now i feel that people have just kind of
resigned themselves uh sadly uh
obviously you haven't personally the
look you've given me but really that
that the basic the sort of broader
community i like the side eye that the
broader community has just kind of given
up and been like yeah you know what
they're just gonna do it and there's
nothing we can do it's easy to feel
powerless because you almost literally
are powerless but i think you have to
continue to fight back and show that
you're not going willingly and you have
to struggle and you have to you know
send messages and call your congress
person and you need to be
united in forces like with the eff you
you can't just like lie down and give up
especially if it's you know your privacy
that's yours that's that's that's sacred
to you yeah and of course you know we're
having all this stuff with net
neutrality and that's looking like it's
going to disappear and uh
it seems to me we had the golden age of
the internet we had it and now we're
shifting it was really good it was free
it was free and it was we got music and
it was and it was there and it was
honest and now we're we're going into
something else what should we call this
evil phase that we're going into i uh
step two i guess i don't know and it's
scary i just saw you know
internationally a lot of international
isps are looking to see how the u.s is
going to rule on net neutrality i i
think it's interesting that in a country
like america that's known for being
politically apathetic at the best of
times we've had a couple of big moments
where we had like the the protest
against the war with iraq originally we
had occupy wall street we had the the
fights over privacy in the wake of the
the snowden revelations but then like
you can only galvanize people for so
long and out of occupy wall street we
got a little bit
but not much but at least we are still
talking about equality and out of the
fights over privacy we got a little bit
in congress but not much but at least
people are thinking about it to some
extent but you just can't keep people
they did get upset when they found out
the nsa was spying on
for
them
until diane feinstein they found out she
you know they were reading her emails
then yeah yeah yeah as soon as john
boehner was involved in the fat bunning
i knew that he'd take it a little bit
more seriously um but you can only keep
people galvanized for so long um a year
is is pretty long to keep activists
working another reason i think twitter
is kind of the the linchpin of this
whole thing is to me it seems that
everything going on in the world all the
revolutions that we see all of the stuff
going on in in ferguson and in hong kong
and what happened in egypt it was all
fueled by twitter that was the one it
wasn't facebook i never if something if
there's some breaking news i never go to
facebook i i wouldn't even think of
going to facebook but you do go to
twitter so is twitter sort of like the
last bastion of this like we really need
twitter to somehow remain independent
right it can be a beautiful thing i mean
we're able to hear about things that we
wouldn't know about like we learned
about ferguson so much after
uh you know so much like locking down
and not speaking but like people were
able to talk and be public and be open
and that was beautiful that's one of the
best parts of the web and social media
yeah and i think it becomes more
ubiquitous people are going to or
officials are going to want to
tighten that down a little bit yeah i
think that twitter is still probably the
premier service internationally for for
that sort of i guess crowdsourcing of
protest but we can't forget that while
twitter remains you know on top in
america internationally there are
regional and country-specific
equivalents that might be taking over
some of that responsibility right are
you have you guys signed up for ello yet
that's what the kids are all they're all
on the yellow over are you on the yellow
you're not on the yellow i'm in line for
ella maybe i know a guy i'll see what i
can do for you all right final thought
on this what do you fear more giant
companies or giant government
it's a bit of a jump from where we
started but i think it's interesting
where are we at now or is it the
companies that we should fear or is it
the government i don't know the answer i
used to always say that it was the
government that i fear giant government
or do you fear them equally sure yeah i
think
is is somewhat simple in that uh we we
benefit from in america the corporations
have bought the government so why not
just fear them and you get both
there you go all right we fear everybody
around here okay let's talk about ufos i
don't fear ufos and there's been a lot
of sightings of ufos uh we've got some
video out of denver's uh kusa tv that's
their mbc affiliate let's take a look
then the talk of the town around
breckenridge all day even if you're now
here at five o'clock i'm about the only
person willing to get in front of the
camera and talk about the ufos that were
flying overhead there was three white
dots i'll show you that were flying over
breckenridge behind me late this morning
looked as if they were hovering right
over baldy mountain behind me and while
no one from the breckenridge police
department or sheriff's departments
wanted to talk about the objects on
camera several people those
organizations saw them and others around
town reported the strange things flying
over the skies of breckenridge sending
police out to investigate the shiny
white tiny dots in the sky some people
off camera said they saw them form
triangles and a line on our camera it
seemed as if they didn't move at all in
fact it took
for most people to even see them the faa
didn't have a comment on what these dots
could be norad said they're not tracking
any abnormalities at this time but
yesterday a tv station in utah reported
very similar white dots appearing in the
sky over utah the objects were visible
for about three hours they showed up
best when the sun was reflecting off
okay so the faa is not commenting on it
the sheriffs won't comment on it so if
it was something legit you'd think maybe
there would be a comment or somebody
would hand somebody a piece of paper or
something uh we've got images uh this is
an image of them one of them it's a
close-up this is taken in utah so i
don't know what the hell that is i have
no idea but a ufo is an unidentified
flying object that doesn't necessarily
mean there's a little green man inside
uh
[ __ ] him
yes unidentified flying object does not
necessarily mean extraterrestrial it
just means we don't exactly have a
handle on what it is right now there has
been some talk that maybe this is a high
altitude helium balloon balloons
it's possible that it is related to a
meteor
i wouldn't necessarily jump to
conclusions yeah okay but i want to jump
to conclusions a little bit because that
because that's that's that's the fun
part right so okay before we get to the
little green man and that whole thing
wouldn't it stand to reason that if
there was something that the government
didn't want us to know about they could
easily pass it off as weather balloon or
they can always give us some explanation
right so until you see the little green
man standing in front of you there's
always a way to get the out unbelief
right yeah well i would say weather
balloon has some connotations that i
think they want to avoid at this point
or swamp gas um i think the fact that it
took place in colorado and utah like if
you're in that quadrant of the country
the chance that it's an experimental
aircraft is magnificently high i think
that that's most likely what it is i
mean i think that if it was like a test
bed for for a new plane or something
like that it's much simpler to just not
say anything provide no information hope
it dies out
we are testing a secret aircraft don't
tell anyone
once people start seeing it if they want
us like don't they have to admit it at
that point then you know what i mean
like shouldn't they be no they don't
they should make us wonder they've done
that in the past
well i don't know what the hell is going
on over it um
it could also be not government related
i mean it could be maybe google's
testing their their gigantic balloons
that are supposed to provide internet
you know around the globe or something
like that i actually have a theory can
we look at the picture one more time
i feel like if you zoomed in you'd see
glinda the good witch floating around in
that that could possibly be i think this
could be a wizard of oz type thing i
think that's more likely than aliens um
all right let's pretend it's aliens for
just a second i have a theory that if
the aliens come here first uh they're
gonna kill us and if we get wherever
we're going you know we're going to mars
now wherever we're going if we get there
first whoever gets there first is going
to kill the other one right we're not
going to is there any chance we're going
to live peacefully with aliens when they
arrive here are we going to welcome them
and and treat them okay
yeah calm down like immediately too many
sci-fi movies a little much yeah you
think really if aliens got here that we
would treat them well and and oh we
would be shitty but we don't necessarily
need to assume that everyone is shitty i
mean maybe they've they've well this is
so theoretical incredibly theoretical
i'm not a kook
um
i don't if they were advanced enough to
come to our planet from whatever far
distance away
i'm hoping that as a society they're not
uh crazy right but wouldn't it stand to
reason that they'd sort of if they if
they were had evolved to the point where
they were going to other civilizations
there might be a reason they're going
there like resources it's sort of like
every you know avatar in every sci-fi
movie like we're going to go
to other planets because we're going to
destroy this place it's pretty obvious
so we're going to wreck this
neighborhood then we got to go somewhere
else and sorry if there's other guys
there that aren't as involved as we are
we might uh mess them up i think this is
one of the reasons i've always liked
russian science fiction because they
have a series of books i think roadside
picnic is the first one where yes they
do kill us but they don't kill us
intentionally they don't go to war with
us it's like if we land on an island
yeah maybe we kill the indigenous
rodents but we're not thinking about it
we don't have a power point about it and
i think like neil degrasse tyson has
talked about if you look at it took just
a couple of million of million years of
evolution and a couple of percentage
points of dna to separate a mouse from a
human i mean the idea that these they
might have evolved you know 10 million
years before us the gap has got to be
even larger than that i mean the idea
that they would even recognize us as
intelligent beings is is difficult to
comprehend they found that golden record
on voyager and they were like oh that's
cute yeah exactly we had chuck berry a
long time ago i mean ants can dig
tunnels but we don't think of them as
intelligent right so is our best hope
then sort of a war of the world
situation where they get here they
probably kill a whole bunch of us but
then they don't factor in that our
environment's a little bit different and
then their machines start to rot and
things like that is that our best and
then tom cruise saves us
well if if it takes at least a no we
can't yeah if it takes at least a few
weeks for them to show up i think the
most likely thing to kill them will be
ebola right it absolutely will be ebola
all right we got one more for you from
aliens to life after death
there was an interesting medical study
on
what what happens to people after they
die are people coming back to life are
they getting to that great white light
let's take a look
a scientist at the university of
southampton have spent four years
examining more than 2 000 people who
suffered cardiac arrest in the uk us and
austria
nearly 40 of people who survived
described some kind of awareness during
the time when they were clinically dead
before their hearts were restarted 13
they had felt separated from their
bodies and their senses had been
heightened and we've got a couple more
uh findings for you one man recalled
leaving his body entirely watching his
resuscitation from the corner of the
room despite being unconscious and dead
for three minutes he recounted the
actions of the nursing staff in detail
and described the sound of the machines
so we hear about this stuff all the time
john's already shaking his head no i
know i've got another skeptic in kim
but we hear about this stuff all the
time and you know i guess there really
is no way of knowing right people aren't
coming back from the dead but it's an
interesting thing uh to think about and
to talk about um
it is interesting look i love the idea
of like resurrection and things like
that i think that that's very
interesting but the thing that always
strikes me about these near-death
experiences or like consciousness after
death is that they're always so
provincial like they always have the
same senses humans have they see things
and they hear things even in the animal
kingdom there are other senses than that
there there you know there's
echolocation there's sensitivity to
magnetic wave like they never have any
new information they only have the same
sort of information a human suspended
from the ceiling could have right well i
guess they're still humans at that point
even if they're trans so maybe we don't
they're spiritual beings they're trend
they've transcended okay so john's given
a pretty sound scientific explanation of
why maybe this isn't real but are some
things just beyond science something
like this is beyond what can be measured
scientifically right i read this article
and i thought okay that's interesting
perhaps the brain is able to
react more than we thought beyond our
current medical standards i didn't read
that as paranormal life after death
that's just it's further of our
understanding of i suppose the human
brain or
perhaps how our trigger
stimuli works when we were
approaching death i don't think that's
any sign of anything paranormal or
spiritual yeah so i think it does bring
up some interesting points because if we
could somehow prove this or quantify
that something actually is happening it
would change how we
uh do end of life things right like
euthanasia and keeping people alive on
machines you might want to extend
people's life if they were in some sort
of
alternate
universe or whatever you want to call it
so it could change how we treat life
right or in the opposite direction if
you knew that there was some life after
death you might just off yourself
and want to experience that i mean for
people who have a shitty situation right
now but feel like this is all they have
if they knew they'd become some sort of
floating wraith being maybe they would
want to kill themselves let's make it
lord of the rings now was that a lord of
the rings yeah right yes it did
i thought that was just very sciencey
but look if they could prove it i would
i would love that i would talk about it
on my show constantly it's just at this
point i don't think that that these
sorts of experiences necessarily provide
you also how this article calls it
biggest ever scientific study is this a
scientific study because were there
properly controlled conditions uh it's a
study right there
i'm saying it is just this yeah and it's
all self-reported and
you know perhaps we're experiencing
things in the human mind that we might
not normally experience when we're close
to death when we have this visceral
reaction of i am going to die
and you know perhaps the subconscious
becomes more aware i don't know but it's
great to study and i think it does
require more study so is that the part
of it that's really the intriguing part
is that fundamentally we will never know
and because we'll never know um
we have to
it's it's sort of prescribes whatever
your life whatever your life meaning is
you can prescribe to whatever the
afterlife is because they're not going
to show you a paper one day and say this
is what happens it's just not going to
happen right yeah or at least not
anytime soon yeah i think you're right i
think that for people who who aren't
particularly scientifically minded or
those who are
an area where science can't yet tread is
definitely interesting and it provides
fertile ground for a lot of interesting
hypothesizing final thought and this is
the meaning of life question do you
think it would take something out of
life if we knew
what it was all about if we knew that
there was an afterlife do you think it
would somehow journey destinations yeah
does it take some of the meaning out of
what we're doing here because to me it
seems like we're i don't know what the
hell is going on after this thing i'm
not even sure what's happening now but
we're here so i do the best i can you
know so i think you would fundamentally
lose something if you actually did know
what was going on after
well john's point about uh the
continuous ritual suicide might become a
thing unless you know your religion says
don't commit suicide
but yeah i very much feel that the
journey is more important the
destination my life is probably more
important than whatever is after my life
because i can feel this and i can see
this i know it's here and i should be
able to put some meaning into it yeah
yeah i think that for some people it
definitely would but i mean even if as a
teenager you're well aware of the fact
that you're going to be an adult at some
point that doesn't mean that you just
disregard your teen years i mean you
still have to experience it you still
learn from it and grow so i would hope
that people by the time we had proof
would be advanced enough to not be
overly swayed by the proof all right
well to recap this week's show isis is
possibly coming to get us but don't
worry americans want to bomb them first
ebola also possibly coming but have
faith in our system or something aliens
possibly coming but maybe they'll be so
evolved they won't want to hurt us and
there might be life after death so we
give you a little bit of everything
follow john and kim on the twitterer
their uh handles are right down below
i was shaking my head at the other thing
yes follow her on on the twitter there
and we'll do it again next week thanks
guys
you